Best Picture nominations this year
American sniper Birdman boyhood the
grand Budapest hotel the imitation game
Selma the theory of everything and
whiplash did any of these movies gross
over 100 million at the box office no
and in fact none of them opened in wide
release they were all they started out
limited release than many of them
expanded into more and more theaters and
the highest grossing film of that lot in
terms of the North American box office
anyway is grand Budapest with 59 point 1
million in that film is currently being
featured on HBO it's on video on demand
it's not even in theaters grand Budapest
opened back in March of 2014 boyhood
open in july of 2014 but grand Budapest
just has so much going for it such a fun
movie a great ensemble cast an amazing
director with Wes Anderson who's such a
visionary so he has always such a
singular vision in his films you can
always tell a wes anderson film right
but Paul two movies came to the party
late Selma and the American sniper
they're just now making their nationwide
big-screen debuts is this unusual well
in both cases both those films opened in
a handful of theaters on Christmas Day
last weekend Selma expanded nationwide
and tomorrow with perfect timing
American sniper will expand into over
3,000 theaters and is expected to top
the weekend could do around 50 million
dollars probably be Clint Eastwood's
biggest debut ever wide release debut so
it is typical for a lot of films to go
into what we call a platform release
opening in a handful of theaters to
qualify within the box office year of
2014 and expanding as they get all this
awards attention both in anticipation of
and in reaction to multiple Oscar
nominations Paul what omission surprised
you during the nominations well there
were a few things that stood out to me
soma was nominated for Best Picture and
Best
a song or score only those two and not
in directing category for Ava Duvernay
and in the acting categories that was a
pretty glaring omission to me also the
lego movie didn't get a nomination for
Best Animated Film and that film it was
so well reviewed it was a big box-office
hit as well so those kind of stood out
to me a bit also wild was not nominated
for best picture but Reese Witherspoon's
performance was and she was terrific in
that film she's a front runner to win
that category although in all the acting
categories it's kind of a toss-up as to
who could win Eddie Redmayne so great as
Stephen Hawking Michael keek Michael
Keaton and Birdman some great
performances out there so it's kind of
anyone's game Paul is there really a
noticeable box office bump from films
that receive these Oscar nominations
yeah we talk about that all the time the
so-called box office boost or bump or
bounce whatever you want to call it and
it really depends on a lot of factors
certainly American sniper is going to
get that because the studio Warner
Brothers is adding a lot of theaters in
reaction to these nominations other
films have been in release for many more
weeks and some will add theaters
sometimes you you create a box-office
bounce by adding theaters for films you
know box-office bounce can be made not
necessarily born in terms of that you
can create that bounce but no question
there's no downside to getting an Oscar
nomination and certainly you will see
the PR machine of all the studio's
ramping up to really tout the fact that
their films what if you look at a
Birdman and grand Budapest both were Fox
Searchlight films nine nominations each
that's a big marketing hook for those
films but of course grand Budapest will
show on our rent track data how well
it's doing on the video on demand space
right in the online space and then for
Birdman still in theaters so that could
get a nice boost there as well Paul we
have a little less than a minute left I
have to ask you who are the favorites to
go on and win the
Oscar's next month well I have to say I
love grand Budapest hotel but remember
boyhood won the golden globe for best
drama so that's kind of a front-runner
there I think in the acting category man
Michael Keaton or Eddie Redmayne any of
those actors JK Simmons was so great in
whiplash and for Best Actress Rosamund
Pike is scary good and gone girl and of
course Reese Witherspoon's so great in
wild but all these actors all these
categories just amazing work in the year
of 2014 but more people will want to see
these films lot of these films haven't
been seen by a massive audience
collectively these films have only
earned about two hundred and eighty
seven million dollars so there's a lot
of box-office gas left in that tank
sniper will add another fifty million to
that bottom line this weekend that's not
the same Rosamund Pike who was in that
James Bond movie what Pierce Brosnan
issue wow she's very scared not at all